fragrant pine trees snowy streets  spacious log cabins it's the  quintessential mountain town  welcome to jackson hole  china  yeah that's right  china  the town has over 1500 homes  most residents use this place as a  weekend getaway from the hustle and  bustle of beijing but there's another  reason they come here  a shared passion for the american west  my name is  i'm from beijing china he's lived here  for seven years and has fully embraced  the lifestyle of the town i like  american  film  especially west film yes  john wayne  there's no ski resort in jackson hole  china but they do have a church which  looks straight out of little house on  the prairie a disney store and a whole  lot of american-style suburban sprawl  many  american people come here and think wow  it's  a wild place  it's a slice of americana and only two  hours northwest of beijing  you